papa je vais une permanente quoi
comprend toujours pas pourquoi tu passe
tellement de temps à essayer d'être
belle tu devrais être réaliste toi tu
seras mignonne dans le meilleur des cas
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut aujourd'hui je
voudrais des anglaises des anglaises
très légères ou naturelles ressemble à
un chien à cause de cette conne
qu'est-ce que tu arrivé à la tête j'ai
fait une permanente tu veux dire que tu
as fait ça volontairement ne déteste ça
commence à nous je les hais ce film on
dirait que ta libido foulques jeanne je
viens te mettre ma perruque mais
d'accord tu veux qu'on fasse à langer
allez fais toi plaisir on a besoin
d'être une annonce sur un panneau on va
finir avec un tueur en série qui ici a
peur de sa femme dit moi j'ai peur que
ma femme se bourrer la gueule et me
[ __ ] la honte en public à nouveau je
crois qu'une famille
c'est comme une voiture on peut la syrie
ou la laisser son crafter et identifie
parfois tu te rends compte que dans
certaines étapes et a tiré dans tous les
sens pour survivre vous m'avez appelé
parce qu'une petite se fait persécuter
et elle ces parties boisées sont déjà
attaqués au chat
c'est notre chance on va enfin pouvoir
battre ces filles c'est pas le gage de
l'autre côté c'est faire preuve de
volonté surmonter peur tokyo une
perruque
la journée a été génial non c'est faux
j'étais avec toi tu te souviens
ac c'est moi l'enfant et tué la culture
[Musique]
je sais que les problèmes de ta mère
elle ne connaît fichtrement rien sur le
fonctionnement du monde
on est une famille tu dois te battre toi
tu veux de m contre moi où est ton
courage ce manque pas de courage il est
où le tient bien courage et mon deuxième
prénom jeunes si tu étais un magazine je
prendrai un abonnement je peux m'abonner
[Musique]
à